model heidi klum zelebriert ihren
hochzeitstag mit einer liebeserklärung
auf instagram schreibt sie
tom ich verliebe mich jeden tag neu in
dich ein jahr nach der hochzeit auf der
onassis sagt christina feiert das paar
erneut zwar ohne freunde und fans dafür
ausgelassen und zuckersüß mit der
familie
erstmals zeigt sie auch ihre kinder leni
henry und johan ganz offen allerdings
als marzipanfiguren auf einer torte
das sieht aus wie die jacht auf der
heidi und tom getraut worden
und natürlich sieht man auch das paar
verliebt am bug des schiffes stehen wer
das schon für perfekt und kitschig hält
kennt heidi nicht um die erinnerung
perfekt zu machen schneiden sie die
torte mit einem messer an auf dem die
namen der verliebten mit einem herzen
eingraviert sind danach wird es kitschig
stadt in einem luxushotel oder am strand
feiert das paar ihre liebe in einem mega
romantischen mit kerzen dekorierten vip
zelt mit blick auf los angeles davor ein
lagerfeuer auf dem sie marshmallows
grillen
[Musik]
überhaupt zeigt sich heidi klum seit der
ehe mit tom vermehrt im hippie look und
total natürlich ohne make-up sie posiert
im stroh und versucht sich mit pinsel
und leinwand als künstlerin so viel
lebensfreude sieht man gern besonders
schön regelmäßig albern die beiden
miteinander rum und auch die kinder
kommen nicht zu kurz so sieht man wie
tom mit blue im garten flieger spielt
bevor er mit heidi augenzwinkernd eine
gespielte bruchlandung hinlegt in ihrem
post schreibt heidi in der liebe
versinken und verlieren sich alle
widersprüche des lebens möglicherweise
spielt das model so auf den
altersunterschied von 17 jahren an
hierbei place to be finden liebe kennt
keine grenzen
auch die familie gratuliert ihr über
instagram heidis älteste tochter leni
schreibt pioneer mama und tom novy bor
und auch glückwünsche von toms
zwillingsbruder bill dürfen nicht fehlen
happy birthday mister und misses kaulitz
lobby tumor the world
[Musik]